- UFO researchers have suggested
that the US Military
secretly built an installation
on the surface of the moon,
to help combat an alien threat.
If there are extraterrestrials
visiting the earth,
and they're
potentially hostile, it
would make a great
deal of sense that we
would be prepared for this.
NARRATOR: A secret military
installation on the moon?
Could such claims,
along with those
made by former Canadian
defense minister
Paul Hellier, and Apollo
astronaut Edgar Mitchell,
really be true?
Perhaps further clues can be
found by examining recently
declassified documents.
July 20, 2014.
The United States Army
declassifies and discloses one
of its biggest secret missions.
Project Horizon.
Project Horizon's mandate was
to create, by 1966, three years
before the first NASA
landing of men on the moon,
a military base which could
hold at least 20 individuals,
and which would be expanded
on over time, as well.
It would be nuclear powered,
it would have its own water
supply, oxygen. And it really
would be the moon equivalent
of a military installation.
The feeling was, from
the Wernher von Braun,
from NASA, and indeed from
the entire government,
that space would become
an important battlefield.
We talk about
conventional warfare,
and how that would play out.
It's fairly clear that if
there is another war that space
will be a battlefield.
The United States has
been working for a long time
in building new weapons
based on the technology
that they've gained.
If you control one of the
approaches to the Earth,
it gives you an advantage that
you wouldn't otherwise have.
Also, it's a launching
pad for anything
you want to do on Earth.
NARRATOR: Could it be,
as some ancient astronaut
theorists contend, that
the US military was
successful in the construction
of a military base
on the surface of the moon?
While the stated mission goal
was to establish dominance
over the Soviet Union
during the Cold War,
many believe the
effort was not against
an antagonistic
global superpower,
but an unknown
extraterrestrial force.
JASON MARTELL: This is
even further expanded
upon when we look
at Reagan's legacy,
and some of these things like
the Star Wars initiative.
So it's very possible that when
we look at what was happening
in the Cold War era, maybe they
were trying to divert attention
to what was really going on.
And that could
have been some type
of collaboration between
us and Russia of putting
a space base on the moon.
Or doing some other
type of space platform
that currently now exists
within our solar system.
There is no doubt in my
mind that Star Wars, initiated
by President Reagan, was more
related to the possibility
of being able to take the
extraterrestrials on for size
than it was against
rogue states.
All of the best
information available
is that it was more intended as
a possible defense against UFOs
than it was against
rogue missiles.
NARRATOR: Did the recent
disclosure of Project Horizon
only serve to try
to dissuade inquiry
into a real and escalating
military presence in space?